so are you would you consider yourself a
red pill mgtow or neither uh probably
red pill is the space that I uh probably
would be categorized okay but we promote
the free agent lifestyle over here okay
what's that the free agent lifestyle is
men's guide to Peace Quiet and freedom
right so it's a level up between uh men
who don't date then men who are in an
active Market of pursuing a lifestyle
that's going to be more advantageous to
them in our world the world that it
exists today all right that's the free
agent lifestyle yeah and how did you get
to that point like what did you have a
red pill moment I've noticed a lot of
guys in the space like there was like
one moment that maybe was their red pill
moment uh men unfortunately get their
red pill moments right we get we get we
get introduced to life because we don't
have the advantage right of being
selected early and often many of us
don't many men do but most of us don't
and we go through trying to succeed with
women right that's where the void is we
try to succeed with women and then
ultimately we hit that moment of reality
that's that red pill moment we get some
double dose of reality or we hit our
head five or ten times for me it was a
marriage then a divorce and then
re-entering the dating Market as a man
that was uh married for 10 years and do
we I re-entered the market dating
Millennials and gen Z okay as a man who
was married in a stable household for 10
years almost 10 years okay that that was
the introduction like this is different
something's different than when I was
pursuing my wife and then married her
and then lived with her and then there
was a new world out there so that was
the red bill moment what was the bigger
shock the divorce or the dating scene
the dating scene the dating scene yeah
the divorce you kind of saw coming yeah
I mean that's just kind of the the
natural course of things obviously I
dealt with some legal issues related to
the divorce right and so that was a red
pill moment it was like what is this but
it wasn't the thing that got me right
and a lot of people think they watch my
content and they're like that's the
thing that guy him and he's just mad his
marriage didn't work out we actually
parted ways amicably but the divorce
grinder that was like what the hell is
this right so at that point I was
getting some information but once I was
re-entering the daily Marketplace that
was when I was like something is
something's up what is the divorce
grinder oh the divorce grinder is when
lawyers get involved in your marriage
right and so what happens is they gotta
they gotta they got to separate the
marriage they got to separate the two
people legally which is not easy many
times people will be married for five
years and it takes two years to get a
divorce
and it doesn't make sense so you're
dealing with the legal issues of
detaching two corporations which is the
husband and the wife and people get a
reality check of what marriage really is
can you tell me a little bit about the
divorce laws the divorce law okay so
because that's one thing when I first
entered like the red pill space yeah I
grew up two-parent households my parents
are still married so I was like why
don't these people want to get married
I'm like it's a I'm like it's a it seems
like a great thing right after I come
from a woman's perspective it seems like
a great thing yeah from a male
perspective is not why isn't it because
the state is attached to these marriages
essentially you're entering into a
business contract this is the stuff
people get pissed off about talking
about because it it bursts the fantasy
bubble yeah right what I'm going to talk
about is like oh but what about love and
what about kids yeah but it's still a
business contract so what happens is
most marriages gonna end in a divorce
and the laws are going to be dictated
based on your country or your city or
your state so they're all different and
if you just happen to so get divorced in
a place
where the law suck
then it's going to be a worse experience
some people get divorced in a place
where they don't suck or they just
halfway suck so it just depends on your
state like California for instance is
considered one of the worst places to
get divorced I was getting divorced in
California
so my whole perspective of divorce is
like whoa all right these people uh look
there as a matter of fact some of the
most wealthiest divorce attorneys are in
California so they have an incentive to
people get divorced they want people to
get divorced obviously to stay in
business and when you find that out the
divorce laws are then introduced to most
men
at that point
now my content we introduced the divorce
laws to men before they get married
so that gives them an idea of what
they're getting into most men aren't
introduced to divorce laws until
the woman says I'm divorcing you and
then it's done because the women were
basically paid to leave aren't we you
have great incentives yeah what
incentives are those great incentives I
mean incentives to be supported by what
they were called maintenance spousal
support or alimony those are all
maintenance spousal support and Alamo
they're considered the same thing just
depending on where you are what state
you are those three words are used
interchangeably but uh oddly enough
feminists are opposed to that as well oh
they're opposed to that most staunch
feminists don't like maintenance or uh
sponsor support either this is what
people don't understand they think
feminists are just going to agree to
have an advantage in the Family Court
they look at that as a negative as well
because they want to be able to be so
supportive and all of that stuff so yeah
really the feminists I've talked to I I
I'll tell them to get a job
instead of like trying to cash out some
feminists are not really feminist yeah
we attribute their where we use that as
a blanket term to describe people who
who like the red hair crazy feminists
those are those people typically more
agree with many red pill guys there's
just a kind of different call to action
I think some people ride the wave of
feminism they're not really feminists
so and then what about child support so
there's you got those yeah child support
yeah tell me about child support is the
the evil empire
so you have child support so you have
the spousal maintenance or or spousal
support
and then you have child support which is
a second payment
it's calculated completely different
from spousal support spousal support
dictated on how long you were married
and that's like alimony okay yeah so
depending on how long you were married
or who was the primary Breadwinner which
typically is mostly men because that's
how women select but child support is
based on how many kids you have
if I have kids in a prior relationship
if my income significantly greater than
hers it depends on what state
so then you can get a double penalty you
leave out playing spousal support and
child support and they're both sometimes
they're both collected by different
agencies so I yeah because that that was
the big like shock to me is like women
are basically because isn't child
support dictated by how much like who
has the kids so it almost gives women
incentive to take the kids to fight for
the custody yes yeah because then they
get more money most typically you're
going to hear a woman say I want primary
custody right right which gonna mean she
wants an advantage on that time wise uh
what the the excuse they'll use is that
I raise the kids I was a primary uh
parent he worked he traveled he was
never there he cheated whatever it is to
get out of that he can't take care of
them because he works a certain schedule
he travels he's an alcoholic he's an
abuser that's why he shouldn't have the
kids that's how this Frame but we have
to understand that there's a calculation
gonna give her more money the more more
time she has but here's the trip you
want to hear something funny when we
when we say that most people say nah
that's not the case she just wants more
time to give the kids more stability
right
but men will say I deserve my parental
rights to have the kid equal time
you know what the woman would say in
that situation
he just wants more time so he can pay
less child support
uh oh it's like a loot it's like a
lose-lose yeah because I just said she
wants more time to get more child
support so they then switched it back
and say he just wants more time so he
can pay less child support yeah and
that's that's what I I really did not
understand when I first started watching
red pill content I was like I was like
why are these guys so against marriage
like this seems like a great a great
thing yeah I mean in in if it was
controlled by Church controlled by
communities is it is this is how
communities are built so people think
that I'm anti-marriage but I'm pretty
traditional in the in the aspect of the
best way to raise children in a
two-parent household I know that I
understand that but we can't even do
that we can't do that as a community so
what happens is the state has to get
involved and the state has to do its
best to find a way to support women who
are now being
volunteering themselves out of marriage
but they can't support themselves 100 so
their state you know there's resources
that they reach to eventually and then
there's also a penalty to the guy saying
well you married her so thus you have to
support her to a certain extent and for
a long time it was like you have to
support her forever then they put in
rules and laws to say this is you're
going to support her until she can get
on her feet I get a job that's right
yeah but you're also saying the women
who violent who said I quit my job my
career to be a mother and a wife you got
lucky right that's what I said I'm like
why are you entitled to money half the
time they're the ones leaving half the
time it's almost damn near all the time
wait well and even that statistic is
skewed right so we say 70 of divorces
are filed by women and then 80 or 90
when it's college educated but that's
but that's skewed because a lot of times
women won't file the divorce to punish
the man
oh shut up I've never thought about it
so what happens is that the guy says I'm
leaving you for another woman
well legally she's not going to file a
divorce
because he's going to marry another
woman or he's going to be out there
dating so in order to prevent him from
finding another partner she'll stop the
divorce proceedings or at least halt it
yeah so there's a lot more so then but
by that point the guy says I'll file so
then he files and gets the process
started that's only one because
otherwise he knows he's going to lose so
so the divorces are that are filed by
men or don't even count as the man filed
it is the woman that won the divorce but
she won't she'll drag the proceedings to
prevent him to marry wow you just red
pilled me a little more well you here
with the master you're here with the
number one the notorious CGA you in the
bunker right now so as many of you know
I was just banned on Tick Tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible